[Music]  good morning nate it's looking mighty  fine out there thankfully no red to  highlight on the highway system so no  major slowdowns  we go to the downtown area where it  looks like we have a pretty wide  wide open right there wide open lane so  we go up to the north las vegas area  where we have one  closure that is creating some minor  slowdowns for people in that area  we're talking about the i-15 southbound  that is closed  right at tropical parkway scheduled to  stay closed until six o'clock this  morning detour is pretty easy  the detour will send you up through the  215 and then off through lamb  so let's give you an update to what we  saw earlier we had some flashing lights  off to the right shoulder on the i-15  northbound near sahara looks like that  is out of the way  we have one two three four five wide  open lanes highway speeds there  and as we take another look at the  highway system thankfully no issues